Jetzt steht es fest: Dem Bau des größten
Radioteleskops der Welt steht nichts mehr
im Wege - ein entsprechende Abkommen wurde
im März unterzeichnet!
Das “Square Kilometre Array” soll laut
Plan aus tausenden Antennen in Afrika und
Australien bestehen, die per Glasfaserkabel
vernetzt sind.
Spätestens 2030 soll das Mega-Teleskop an
den Start gehen und 100 Mal empfindlicher
sein jedes andere derzeit aktive Radioteleskop.
Und auch die Ziele des Projekts sind wirklich
mehr als ehrgeizig: Unter anderem soll ein
3D-Weltraumatlas erstellt werden, der uns
einen Blick in das frühe Universum ermöglichen
könnte.
Auch der Dunklen Energie und Außerirdischem
Leben könnten wir mit Hilfe von “Square
Kilometre Array” endlich auf die Spur kommen.
Alles zu diesem weltweit einzigartigen Projekt
erfahrt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction
- herzlich willkommen!
Das ist wirklich eine Entscheidung, die die
Astrophysik weit weit nach vorne bringen wird!
Das Projekt “Square Kilometre Array” (SKA)
soll nämlich nicht weniger als die weltweit
größte Wissenschaftseinrichtung werden.
Seine Infrastruktur soll sich über drei Kontinente
auf der Nord- und Südhalbkugel erstrecken;
sein Hauptquartier hat die Einrichtung in
Großbritannien.
Tausende Einzelantennen und hunderte von Parabolspiegel
bilden zwei Beobachtungsnetzwerke, die sich
sich über hunderte Kilometer in Südafrika
und Australien erstrecken.
Die gebaute Antennenfläche des Mega-Teleskops
soll dann 1.000.000 Quadratmeter betragen
und eine schnellere Durchmusterung des Himmels
möglich machen als je zuvor.
Heraus kommt dabei nicht nur eine 50 Mal höhere
Auflösung als die Bildauflösung des Hubble-Weltraumteleskops,
sondern zudem auch eine unvorstellbare Menge
an Beobachtungsdaten, die verarbeitet werden
muss.
Das werden nur die schnellsten Supercomputer
der Welt schaffen.
Fest steht: Rund 600 Petabyte sollen pro Jahr
gespeichert werden.
Das entspricht 600 Billiarden Byte, also der
Speicherkapazität von mehr als einer halben
Million Laptops - das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Diese unvorstellbar große Datenmenge wird
dann zur Auswertung an die Wissenschaftsgemeinde
verteilt.
Jedenfalls wurde Ende März endlich der entscheidende
Grundstein für das SKA gelegt.
Sieben Staaten haben in Rom das Abkommen für
den Bau des weltgrößten Radioteleskops unterzeichnet.
Dabei sind Südafrika, Portugal, die Niederlande,
Italien, China, Australien und Großbritannien.
Caterine Cesarsky, die Vorsitzende des SKA-Gremiums,
sagt zu dem unterzeichneten Abkommen: “Rom
wurde auch nicht an einem Tag erbaut.
Entsprechend werden der Entwurf, der Aufbau
und schließlich der Betrieb des größten
Teleskops der Erde jahrzehntelange Anstrengungen,
Sachkenntnis, Innovation, Durchhaltevermögen
und globale Zusammenarbeit erfordern.
Heute haben wir den Grundstein dafür gelegt,
um das SKA schließlich Wirklichkeit werden
zu lassen“.
Auch Indien und Schweden wollen sich beteiligen;
das steht aber noch nicht endgültig fest.
Sicher jedenfalls ist, dass Deutschland raus
ist.
Sehr zum Unmut vieler deutscher Forschungsteams
und der Wissenschaftscommunity, da das SKA
als eines der vielversprechendsten Wissenschaftsprojekte
überhaupt gilt.
Den Ausstieg aus dem Projekt und der Finanzierung
hatte die deutsche Bundesregierung im Sommer
2014 verkündet - mit fatalen Folgen für
deutsche Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler.
Denn nur wer zahlt, darf das Mega-Teleskop
auch nutzen.
Die geplanten Forschungsschwerpunkte des SKA
jedenfalls können sich sehen lassen.
Fachleute sind sich sicher, dass sie mit Hilfe
des Mega-Teleskops fundamentale Wissens-Lücken
in der Physik endlich schließen können.
Denn kosmische Radiowellen entstehen bei vielen
natürlichen Prozessen - beispielsweise werden
sie von Gaswolken im All ausgesendet.
Sie haben eine deutlich größere Wellenlänge
als sichtbares Licht - nämlich zwischen 10
Zentimetern und 100 Kilometern.
Der Vorteil: Sie werden anders als Röntgenstrahlung
oder Infrarotlicht nicht von der Erdatmosphäre
verschluckt.
Mehrere Millionen Galaxien sollten mit Hilfe
des SKA kartiert werden.
So könnte dann auch endlich die Entwicklung
des Universums über Milliarden von Jahren
zurückverfolgt werden.
Auch die Suche nach Leben im Universum wird
durch den Betrieb des SKA wohl noch einmal
weiter voranschreiten und auch auch die Relativitätstheorie
von Einstein könnte unter extremen Bedingungen
getestet werden.
Zudem sind Fachleute optimistisch, dass das
SKA auch dabei helfen wird, endlich der mysteriösen
Dunklen Energie auf die Schliche zu kommen.
Mehr als 1000 Experten und Expertinnen aus
20 Ländern waren bereits in den letzten fünf
Jahren an den Design-Arbeiten für das SKA
beteiligt.
Ende 2020 sollen dann Verträge in einer Höhe
von 700 Millionen Euro an Anbieter in den
Mitgliedsstaaten gehen, damit das SKA konstruiert
werden kann.
Auch die deutsche Forschergemeinschaft hat
weiterhin großes Interesse an dem Projekt
und plant die Gründung des “Vereins für
datenintensive Radioastronomie”.
Dazu Stefan Wagner von der Universität Heidelberg:
“Die gesamte astronomische Gemeinde hat
schon lange auf ein Radioobservatorium mit
solch hervorragender Leistungsstärke auf
der Südhalbkugel der Erde gewartet.
Die Gründung einer Organisation für den
Aufbau und den Betrieb dieses Observatoriums
ist ein entscheidender Schritt vorwärts.
Wir als Astrophysiker in Deutschland sind
sehr daran interessiert, beim SKA mitzumachen,
das Einblicke ins Universum weit über die
derzeit vorhandenen Möglichkeiten bieten
wird.“
Bislang beteiligt sich die deutsche Forschergemeinschaft
an Vorläuferprojekten wie dem MeerKAT-Radioteleskop
in Südafrika, das im Sommer 2018 eingeweiht
wurde.
Ob wir den Fuß da noch in die Tür bekommen?
Wir bleiben dran!
Das berühmteste Radiosignal der Welt: Was
ist das Wow!-Signal?
- Draufklicken, anschauen und natürlich abonnieren
Weltraum-Wissen von Astro-Comics TV Bis dann,
bleibt dran!